hey guys how's it going welcome back to
spooky snacks we're getting real festive
here in my kitchen I'm just saying if
you're new here if you're not welcome
back you guys already know how things
roll today we are going to be making
these really cute witch
cupcakes I don't know really what to
expect but that's usually to be expected
here
first things first we've got some candy
melts it's been really hot recently in
Los Angeles so wherever these candy
melts came from
they're kind of already melted in here
so we're gonna get these started in our
little melting pot cut this open if it's
just one big solid chunk let that do
whatever it is gonna do hopefully melt
we're gonna ice up our little cupcakes
you're also gonna need a little cone you
need a pointy cone because this is gonna
be our witches hatch you need some icing
you can get whatever kind we chose cream
cheese you're also gonna need some
little cupcake liners I think that's
what they're called you're gonna cut a
little hole in them just like this a
little hole to get things started let's
ice up our little cupcakes but just ice
it up real nice real nice if you like to
add a little more you can more or less
the taste it's really up to you you can
do whatever you want you can be the best
you can
let me look at my picture these never
really look like a picture that looks
mediocre we've got our cupcake size
we've got our melted candy black candies
and now we're going to paint the ice
cream cones this is a real crucial part
of this because it's basically the whole
entire point of this delicious delight
so here we go let's start painting I
have absolutely no idea where I got this
brush from I believe you can use it for
food I'm using it for food I love
Halloween it's my favorite holiday
aside from Easter I love Easter because
I love Easter eggs okay once you've got
one of your little hats I'm assuming you
just stick it on top of the cupcake
because that's what the picture looks
like
looks just like the picture and then
you're gonna put this up yep
then you're gonna put the top of its
little thing I think it looks good
no I think it looks good you know
honestly you probably should wait for
the cone to cool this looks almost
exactly like the photos what do you
think yeah it looks really good
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed our little witch
cupcakes definitely slightly debatable
on the outcome I think they are on a
scale of one to ten four make sure you
guys stay tuned for tomorrow's video
where we'll have another spooky little
snack for you
this really isn't spooky the only thing
spooky is the fact that it doesn't
really look much like the picture that I
tried I'll see you guys later thanks for
watching bye they are these weird little
teeth Apple they look like this I really
don't have any directions so basically
just gonna try to replicate that I've
got my apples and we're gonna just we're
gonna do it we're going to cut them then
we run with a peanut butter in them and
then we're gonna make these little
smiles